what's up beautiful people welcome to
another episode of get close i am geo
and um
why
oh
i [ __ ] hate when flies do that no i'm
not a fly i'm gen z
oh
are you
yeah that is so
last year dude no that's that's like uh
the gen z like in sign language when you
go to sign language school when you
teach you how to do like you know for
the news where it's like and then like
two people got shot at the store thing
and then they were a gen z
what is [ __ ] happening in your brain
right now
what is that what is that uh that's that
tick tock uh like what is going on in
their head oh no that's that's what
literally what they teach you at sign
language school fine okay so um i will
give a bug
yeah i really do i don't know where
you're going with it
so
uh as you know
as we all know as we've all seen your
papa has been living with us now for
about
three four months really [ __ ] it feels
like
it feels
it feels like a long time for me at
least and the reason why he's living
with us is because um he decided he
wanted to live out here to be close to
you and to taika doesn't give a [ __ ]
about me he does care about you he does
care about you for the record yeah um i
don't mind i really don't mind and uh
and the only
so i i had come up with the idea of like
well wait
why are you guys gonna wait until buying
a house because every day that you wait
the prices are going up
so don't wait just get the house now
let's get it get built it's going to
build equity as it's even getting built
because everyone is just coming into
town yeah just to backtrack a little bit
because i feel like you jumped right
into the middle of it so my dad yeah so
my dad was at a crossroads
where he wants to move here to be closer
to me and taika
but
um he was like oh [ __ ] but i gotta sell
my house because it's at peak market in
order to buy a house and that's where
you came in where you're like well why
don't you just
sell your house because i think the
typical thing what that people do
is they'll buy the house right
when it's completed
now i'll sell the current house got it
so i can move in
but uh
you you came up with the really dope
idea of like well
if you wait the market shifts all the
time so you might not get peak dollar
for your house
and um you just wanted to make sure he
was maximized on both ends yeah so
you're like what about this why don't we
sell your house early
so that you can capitalize into peak
market because even now from from then
until now we've seen interest rates hike
up like crazy we've seen sellers adjust
their price yeah so that was a really
good call on your end my dad
got top dollar for his house which is
amazing and you're like and so instead
of like being homeless you could just
come stay with us and then that way you
get
your current house at the lowest price
and you sell your house at the highest
price yep you'll be able to get a great
daughter-in-law move on your hand thank
you so much even though he doesn't care
about me he does um so then he moved in
with us everything's been fine he's uh
very helpful he is hard at hearing he
doesn't speak english but he he tries
his very best to you know respect
like whatever it is that we got going um
even though he didn't hard hearing is
kind of like
uh understatement i think he's deaf
he's pretty deaf i mean he could still
hear us but it's hard
i mean
if someone goes
ba-ba
he doesn't even hear that though
oh
like that's pretty deaf as [ __ ] yeah
he's pretty deaf as [ __ ] but he's not
deaf we don't need sign language like he
could i could still yell and he gets
what i'm saying yeah you can yell at him
he's like
no no no it's not that crazy but it's
pretty bad yeah um
yeah but he does he he really want it
feels like at least or maybe he's just
doing the asian dad thing but he feels
it feels like he wants to just give us
space at times
um
which is i'm like you don't have to
right like we're all a family like we
should all be together anyway like my
mom is with us now and like
not with us but she's just visiting for
a little bit um and we're always
together we have all our meals together
we like anytime we're done with work we
all congregate at the same spot but your
dad just is like
he i think he just wants to i'm assuming
here that he wants to just give us our
space yeah he does um so
we did a podcast where i talked about
like what that's like because you and
him had such a turbulent
relationship growing up that
when your parents split up
um you ended up living with your mom
you were getting in so much trouble that
he was like hey you know what let me try
to take over let me see what's going on
let me see if i can reach out to our son
and get him on the right path you live
with him for maybe like a year or two
no i finished maybe like
16 17 18 with him okay three years up to
19 probably three four years with him
before i had to move out and then uh the
relationship between you guys got so
[ __ ] bad that like
it was just fighting throwing [ __ ] like
just really really bad situation so then
you're like i can't live with this guy
we have to part ways you end up
living on your own yeah okay so i moved
down when i was 19. yeah and then since
then relationship has never really like
repaired itself but it did get
um
better because you guys were apart so
you would like grab dinner with him or
whatever but it was never like
we've patched things up we're homies
we're like father-son let's do the
father-son thing right it's always been
like this weird he's more of an uncle
than a dad type of space yeah okay so
now
that you've
been living with him
it's been a few months already
i've seen a lot of growth from you and
i've seen yeah and i've seen
and i don't know if this growth is good
or it's bad but i think it was necessary
so
um you've talked about how like you've
been really suppressed growing up
because i mean that's just the asian
structure
layered on top of your own parents very
opposite structures that are also very
extreme that they put on you
and now you've been actually i don't
want to say standing up to them because
that sounds like you're rebelling and
like you're puffing out your chest but
you have been setting healthy boundaries
with them and kind of like letting them
know like where you stand as a man with
your family
and
how the dynamic should work
and like i think that's huge because
i've never seen you like in our entire
relationship i've only seen you maybe do
that
one time or two times and and like i
just kind of wanted to like
see what's going on now
i definitely sense a pivotal moment in
myself
because i think um and i think a lot of
uh
not just asian americans but probably a
lot of uh immigrant families can relate
to this
where there's such an importance placed
on respecting your elders and doing what
the team wants or needs or even the
family name or the legacy
that a lot of your own personal wants
and desires gets kind of like pushed to
the side right yeah because then you're
selfish in a piece of [ __ ] yeah across
the board so i've seen people go i got
accepted to this college and the parents
can i go and their parents are like way
across town think about grandma
right so kind of like some sort of like
even success gets pulled back
or um
hey my my boyfriend uh is going to take
me out well you better take your like
little sister too or just so just across
the board like not just like in the
funsy stuff but in the serious stuff
there's that like
you better sacrifice a little bit of
self
for
the greater the greater good right so if
you're like you better put that
saxophone down
you should go be a contractor or
something like that right that's like
pretty
normal so i think i've had that my first
big moment was jk where i was like you
know what i'm going to live my life and
pursue an occupation for myself that was
my first real break from the nest right
so i did jk and then i was able to get
it on his feet and that leveraged into
barbara brigade and all the other stuff
that we've been able to do so in terms
of my profession i think i had that big
pivotal moment i'm living for myself
then when it comes to uh like being a
son
and also like a someone that's gonna
continue the progeny
i don't think i've completely
broke free of that because i'm still
like
hey like the grandson has got to be
someone that's really cuny for my mom
cuny for my dad and i gotta like tie
this whole family together and it's up
to me to like make sure we tie the
family together and so
a lot of the things that they demand
that might not be applicable to this
generation i just kind of bend over
backwards i'm like well this is how the
family is you're you're you're
technically head of the household so
i'll do whatever right
but i think this year especially since
my dad moved in
i
started to feel like
you know what like how i knew
what was best for my profession
i think i also know what's best for my
family
uh immediate or
my immediate family okay
so which is like you and tycho right
um
because i'm i'm part of my dad's
immediate family i don't think he's
actually part of my immediate family
right so because my family is the one
that i'm creating that's how i view
family like whatever family you created
is your immediate is your immediate
that's how everyone uses it yeah and
everyone else is ex the how come you
asked my dad or me i was saying your
immediate family or i was going to say
extended oh i see yes so yeah i view my
dad as extended family right
and because he's moved in and i felt
like in the first month or two i've
really tried my best
to bend over backwards and along with
you right even having him be able to
move in for someone that
values privacy and to be able to move at
a moment's notice that's such a huge
priority for you that's why i was like
actually like taking back i was like oh
[ __ ] well no i mean you make it sound
pretty nuts but when it comes to family
[ __ ] like that's not an issue for me
um well anyways to me i've i i'm looking
at it here not here i see yeah i'm like
wow that's [ __ ]
crazy oh i see yeah because for me it's
like it should always be expected
because it's family
oh well i just know how you are so i was
like that's [ __ ] crazy that you're
down to just have them move in you know
especially how abrasive both of my
parents are
right it's like literally having like
because family's family but if you have
an uncle that is known to be drunk and
beats kids are you gonna let him move in
oh family's family yeah that's what i'm
saying yeah that that's what that got it
that
statement is not a good blanket you're
right you're right okay
yeah so my parents they're very abrasive
we know that so family is not always
family yeah because they come in and
they can wreak havoc and they can cause
even a strain on our relationship right
so um
for our family i was like oh you know
what like
i can already see how this is taking a
strain on our relationship as i'm still
trying to fulfill the what does this
side of the family want what does the
extended family want what does my dad
want right so i'm kind of bending our
family to fit
what his ideals are
and so i think this is the pivotal
moment in my life
this year 2022 where i was like you know
what just like how i know i knew what
was best for my profession and i really
gotta
take the reins on that i need to do
what's best for my family the one that
i'm creating with geo and taika and
possibly the next one right like i need
to
like set healthy boundaries so now
instead of
hey like and this is a more like
metaphorical sense instead of you me and
tyka get on our knees and bow to my dad
it's more like
this is what we're gonna do
hey dad i respect you so much do you
want to come along for the ride
if not then we we're gonna have to live
separate lives and we'll try to visit as
much as we can together um we'll try to
see where we can mesh but we have our
own path
and it's up to you how much you want to
uh it's up to you to how much you want
to match your life to mine and not how
do i match my family's life to yours
and uh and what brought that about
because that's such a huge deviation
from
just culturally and just everything you
that's been instilled in you because
that's massive yeah it's it's actually
[ __ ] huge
and it's not one of those things like
the profession where it's like a
physical move it's all of this stuff
that i'm talking about isn't in the air
right from the outside you don't know
what boundary has been set it's not like
someone is moving from here to this
location or whatever
or like you know it's just it's just
imaginary things so that's kind of like
the more intricate part that's harder to
describe
but i think for me um
having my dad move in now
and talking having a lot of like deeper
talks with my pops
i begin to realize how my dad and my
mom's marriage failed
wow and how my dad's relationship with
even some of his brothers haven't been
the healthiest
and so
kind of seeing how like you know back
then
a lot of talks were very surface level
like people didn't even know how to like
get deep they don't even know the labels
for certain things they don't even know
what mental health is like people talk
about mental health that's like oh
you're just being a [ __ ] [ __ ] or
whatever right yeah yeah so they don't
even know like love languages they don't
understand what being selfish or traumas
or trauma or like triggers
or narcissism or any of that stuff they
don't know what any of that stuff is
they just they just everything is based
off obligation this is my brother i
protect them i'm his brother you know so
it's just by obligation right we got
each other and hard in the [ __ ] and
like hard rules like black and white
rules as much as possible yeah
it's like you spoke back to me therefore
you disrespect me which means you think
i'm a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you yeah yeah
just like whoa whoa not really yeah so
one of the craziest things that came up
is um my dad was like hey you know what
i'm getting older
um your mom's getting older and um
i don't want to die alone i don't think
your mom wants to die alone and
i think uh i'm gonna go see
um if like me and your mom could like
maybe we're not get back together but
maybe we can be friends and have each
other's back until our
lives end
you know and then i was like oh [ __ ]
that was some [ __ ] crazy like that's
something i've never even heard of
and me knowing my mom on her [ __ ]
crazy buddhist [ __ ]
i was like
um i don't think my moms have ever
thought about you
and if you text her i think it's gonna
come out of the blue like crazy because
during the pandemic mom was stuck in
taiwan for two years and she never once
mentioned you she's finally back in
america i think she's just enjoying
her freedoms and just chilling and like
you know like getting back into the
swing of things i think the last thing
she wants
is uh the past coming to honor yeah
exactly
and then um as my dad was explaining
about how like
what his envision what his fantasy is of
like oh but you know we're a family um
it would be cool to see like me your mom
taika and then jill like all sitting on
a dinner table
and i was like
i started to realize
my dad has a lot of imaginary ideals
that um he didn't really put the work in
for yeah you can't just go to my mom and
go hey this is my dream you know
or
even when tycho was born like your mom
came every single day
my dad only came once a week so if taika
doesn't speak chinese to you
you didn't plant those seeds so i would
have these conversations which start
small and i try not to be ever be rude
but it'll be like hey dad i'm like i
would tell them like
you know the fruits you're trying to
pick i don't think you planted those
trees for those fruits
my dad's like what do you mean you said
it like that that's so poetic yeah well
you know
i [ __ ] hate you bars bars bars and
yeah gen z of you to do dude
bars huh
um yeah so i would say like that and my
dad's like what do you mean this is uh
this is how a family is and i'm like
yeah a family in your mind
but only but you didn't
plant those seeds so i'm like oh [ __ ]
what i realized is
my dad is just uh
living off of obligation
off of titles you know you're my son
therefore you should sit across from me
from the dinner table that's my wife but
even though there's a 30-year gap
that's not your wife like the the actual
relationship needs to be nurtured and
watered every single day so that started
to make me see like oh [ __ ] there's a
lot of things that both my mom and my
dad kind of operate on based off
obligation like yo my son's like you'll
do this one you know so it's kind of
like that and i was like
oh [ __ ] so i don't even know if he's
equipped with the tools to know how to
nurture the things that he wants
and so so i'll start to see a little bit
of that and then so he asked me for um
mom's address and contact information
which he doesn't even have
for good reason which means for 30 years
this is gonna be really out of the blue
but i gave it to him anyways and i was
like you know what like that's i don't
i'm like i already know where this is
going i'm like i don't want anything
to deal with you guys communication is
this something that you would have said
in the past like remove yourself from it
or is it like no i would have got i
would have got caught up in the mix
because you have to because i would have
felt so obligated as a son because you
have to right because that's your
obligation yeah so as a son you got to
be like mom and dad regardless of the
divorce or not you're just playing the
sun roll um but this time around i'm
putting on i'm an adult hat
you're an adult hat yeah and wow my
adult hat this is my bandwidth for my
family
um i don't have bandwidth for this
amount of drama that i can see that's
gonna happen so i'll tell my dad i'm
like i can tell you right now
here's mom's information
if you contact her
you contact her
as you're an adult
speaking to another adult
and if she has something to say it's
from that adult
to this adult yeah and you guys
communicate back and forth in no way
shape or form do you want to get pulled
do i want to get pulled in because
there's no there's two adults here you
don't need a third adult to go in the
middle are you okay with that and he
goes yeah i don't see how i could go
wrong or whatever i'm like all right i'm
gonna tell you right now with everything
that i see i'm gonna get pulled in and
everything's gonna go wrong yeah and i'm
like but i'm just letting you know
that's what i see
based off of i'm like and i also told my
dad i'm like um
you know running jk
and barbell
i i've experienced a lot of human
dynamics
like over the years we've hired people
that are older than us younger than us
married
not married different cultural
backgrounds sexual orientation really
hard working people lazy people really
people are down to give it their all
entitled people so like
my like dynamic experience vocabulary
and like if i were to apply that to
basketball my court iq for people is
pretty high so i'm like when i see how
you are as a person how mom is as a
person i can kind of already see where
the dynamics go and he goes wow that's
really smart he's still indeed anyways
so contacts my mom
and uh
apparently
um
my dad ran into my mom at a temple
which is with my dad was with her
brother and i guess they hit it off
which i was like oh
that's cool i mean if you guys ran into
each other that's fine i'm staying out
of this
so my dad pitched my mom his idea you're
getting old i'm getting old um
what if like
you know
maybe we don't rekindle anything but we
can get each other's back because you're
alone america i'm alone in america and i
guess my mom was open to
the
idea of that this whole time your dad's
like huh but i told you maybe and so my
mom was like well you know i do have an
empty room at my house
so you can stay here however long as you
want
and so uh this all happened when
we were spending time in la so my dad
hasn't been able to update me you know
like uh on a
daily
daily
and so my dad ended up taking my mom on
that offer
goes to her house
they start talking
and i think as my dad starts talking
um what my mom thought was like all the
divorce and 30 years of like beef that
she had she thought she could
push it away
but if things aren't resolved
it yeah pops up so like little things
like oh that that i remember that oh my
god i remember that i remember that
remember that i remember that so all
these things that uh
she buried away are now triggers so i
think to protect herself my mom ends up
telling me she calls me and i was like
[ __ ] i [ __ ] knew i was gonna get
pulled into this somehow she told me um
i wrote a contract out you can't not get
pulled into it when you're offering the
address and the number dude i would have
been like i don't know anything don't
tell me anything don't update me i
learned that from my mom and that's so
genius
yeah it's like don't tell me a thing
yeah later yeah yeah so i'm trying so my
mom told me yeah
and she's on my i'm writing out a
contract this is how i want it to be i'm
gonna get it notarized oh you're writing
out the contract no i'm speaking as my
mom uh i'm writing on a contract this is
for between me and your dad we're gonna
get a notarized this is how his code of
conduct has to be because you know my
mom is the like the princess is the the
[ __ ] queen so she's like you uh this
is how we're gonna i work out for an
hour every morning we're gonna walk to
the park you better do that with me like
all these things right and then as she
was telling me i was like i don't know
if uh
dad told your mom
i was like
i don't want to be involved in this so
all the stuff you're telling me now let
that be the last update you tell me
and i'm taking this as an update not as
a i need a transmission of information
because everything that you want to say
you say to him yeah i'm gonna be
completely out of this i'm gonna let two
people deal with this as adults i'm just
setting like healthy boundaries you know
i was like anything that's mom related
with you and me open door always
but with dad
i'm gonna treat it as if that's a new
boyfriend or a new friend that you make
that's
you don't you don't bring me in on all
the gossip on it she's like okay i get
it that's fine oh that's really cool but
i don't think as asian parents they
totally get
what a modern day healthy boundary is
you know
so
she sends that to him
then they start having their
miscommunication of like my dad's like
why do i need this within days yeah like
what do i need to write these rules and
then i would i know i was getting pulled
into it so my dad would come vent to me
and all my dad i [ __ ] told you i was
like i already knew
that it was gonna get to this like
because i told my dad like even before
this whole thing i was like you know
knowing you with my all of my experience
with dealing with like the public and
employees and all this stuff
looking at you and mom i actually don't
think you guys should have ever gotten
married
i was like just looking at who you are
as core people i don't think i don't see
how it could have ever worked out
and uh but i was like but i don't hold
it against you guys i was like when you
guys
both got married um
you guys were both in like your mid-30s
and at that time
it's like you're considered about to
expire tomato
so you gotta like get it expired
tomatoes you know what i mean like in
that day and age it's like if you're 27
you're not married yeah that is pretty
nice you're expired goods yeah right so
i was like so i get your mom had you
when she was 30. yeah 30 something wow
so i was like he's really late yeah so
i'll say okay you guys uh um i
understand the pressure the societal
pressures of the time so i don't hold
any of it against you i don't even hold
it against you you guys got divorced i
think that was a healthy thing it would
have been even more turbulent yeah and
all that you know but i just want to
tell you from my experience how it is it
is what it is i'm gonna continue to live
the best life that i have and i want i'm
gonna try really hard not to repeat that
mistake
so with all that
having been said a few weeks before
i told my dad i was like
what did i say
what did i say man i told you
i'm gonna get dragged into this one two
because you and mom never see eye to eye
you say i wanna live with you she's
gonna come out of left field left field
with i'ma hit you with the contract and
when she hits you with the left field
contract you're gonna be like what the
[ __ ] i'm like that's the entire
relationship i've ever seen for the
first six years of my life it's like no
one's seeing eye to eye on things you
know it's like i'm making a pie well i'm
gonna squirt sriracha on it and the
other one's like what and it's always
been like that and boom fights right
so like this is what i [ __ ] told you
and i was like but
um
i understand where mom's coming from
right she's protecting her she's
protecting herself there's a lot of
unresolved things and you're like oh
your mom always wants to uh like bring
up old beef and all that stuff
i'm like there we go again bringing me
into it i'm like if you have anything to
say
directed at her
mom has anything to say directed at you
right that is
the last thing i want to hear i did my
job giving you the address
and i let both uh mom and dad know that
if you guys want to try to make this
thing work you have the support of me if
you guys want to live
live out your life separately you have
the support of me
ultimately i just want you guys to be
happy no matter how you guys do it and i
want you guys to be a
healthy and happy extension of the
family that i'm trying to create yeah
that's all i care about yeah
so it's just like in the last like month
or two me setting
these um
little boundaries and like me taking my
family by the reins
and having these really adult
conversations
that i never thought i was even capable
of because probably even a year ago i
just always thought like
whatever ideal that my parents have for
a family i was just gonna succumb to
that and it's just gonna be a constant i
serve you i serve you i serve you until
you pass away um even if it's at the
detriment of my family but uh it hasn't
been like that it's been
hey this is this is how it's going to be
you know how was that received
um i think my dad because everything i
come at him it's not with like conflict
it's with my logic
and with me being vulnerable with the
need yes that i'm trying to fulfill i'm
like
disrespect yeah
and i think uh my dad he's been taking
it pretty good like really real like
he'll actually go
okay i see wow oh wow okay i see yeah i
see why how this is like
bad for your family
wow so i think that's why he doesn't
interact that much because i'm like i
let my dad know my hair this is my
instead of just saying like you know
what like your your involvement it's
like [ __ ] my family dynamic i think
that's gonna cause a fight right yeah
that's so mean too i know but out of
heat people can say stuff like that yeah
so i think what i told my dad is i was
like you know my family time is
extremely precious and i'm like so for
example i'm like you see me and geo like
train in the morning right right after
we train we go to work i mean when we're
at work i'm like you know what our
relationship is he's like what i'm like
we're co-workers
we're we're straight-up co-workers and
we talk to each other very straight no
cuny no vulnerable no nothing when it's
lunch time i'm like do you see when me
and jill come downstairs to have lunch
for that 30 minutes i'm like do you see
me and jill on her phone he was like no
i'm like because that's very intentional
cuny time for us
so now we're in a relationship
right when that 30 minutes is over we're
back to co-workers so when we finish
like work at 405
i'm like that whole day
it's all co-workers i'm like do you
think we have time to um nurture our
romance or nurture our relationship he's
like no i'm like okay cool so that
hasn't been even though we spent all day
together none of the
relationship has been nurtured right he
goes yes now we take taika to like jiu
jitsu or we hang out we come back home
and we have dinner now it's our family
time i'm like and so taika goes to sleep
back around nine o'clock how much family
time do we actually have per day and
then he was like like two to three hours
i'm like yeah so out of the whole day i
only have two to three hours as a family
so like if my number one
uh my number one and two is to nurture
my relationship and then to nurture my
family i'm like how much time do i have
to nurture my extended family
which is why i was like you can always
come along for dinners and stuff like
that but knowing that if you have a
presence and if you have a need and then
i need to serve that need that's going
to take away from some of this yeah
right and then he's like so i think like
walking him through it
helping him see it
um
made him be able to go like oh [ __ ] i
know where you're coming from coming
from versus his more idealistic mindset
it's like well we're just all one big
family why can't we just all hang out
every single day
when we can like like so that's what i
was that's what i was alluding to right
when i was like bringing up my mom as
the example of like it is possible for
sure it's possible and i actually would
enjoy it right like because then we
would still have like we can do a date
night because now like there's so many
things getting developed and there's so
many relationships that are getting
nurtured all at the same time the
relationship between me and your dad is
getting nurtured the relationship
between you and your dad getting
nurtured your dad and taika uh you know
like you and taika like there's just so
many cross nurturings happening that it
makes the family a lot stronger i think
the only thing that is the biggest issue
is one
um maybe your dad's misunderstanding the
dynamic that we want or it's like we do
want to all eat together because you do
invite him to eat with us right and then
he'll serve himself eat and then he
bounces and i'm like well wait i thought
the point was so that we can all be
together um or another one is he's just
talking to you the entire time no one
else exists and i'm like well that's
also not
including the whole like that's not a
family conversation it feels like oh
should me and tyka leave the room
because we're like interrupting your
guys's
like one-on-one you know um because i
would love that i would like us to have
like that family time you know because i
would include him as an immediate family
member even though it is technically
still going to be on the extended side
um
but i don't know i think he just
operates differently well the biggest
difference between him and your mom is i
think your mom understands that this is
our family and we're need to take this
family through its journey and she's
tagging along with this family's mission
right so i think she understands that so
she
what does she do that that so all of her
involvement doesn't derail from the
mission i think my dad is he has his own
mission and he wants to take the family
and derail it from not like uh not bad
right but what he wants is going to end
up having this family being
derailed from that mission to match his
mission what is his mission
just to spend time and be able to look
at taika like all day and look at me oh
they already look at you all day
oh and that's it yeah
don't lie he doesn't want to look at me
all day um i see
so i think that's the biggest thing like
one is like i'm
adding on to this carpool and the other
one's like i'm driving the car i see
yeah i see i see
yeah and that is different because i
don't know if that's just an asian thing
right because i thought you said like at
least specifically for chinese
the grandma is like the head honcho
no i mean it's generally always the
grandpa
across all east asians it's a very very
similar structure yeah i see i mean you
have some like tough moms like david
soul's mom you know um you have like
some outliers like that that call the
shots will wear the pants or whatever
but generally it's
okay
yeah yeah so it's similar okay yeah
cause then like um
like at least for my family structure
the dad or grandpa would still like yeah
he comes into the family and stuff but
you still want to like cater to that
you know like he's not gonna try to
derail anything though i don't think my
dad's trying to derail yeah
same that's what i'm saying like they're
not trying to but they still have their
own thing
like their own agenda
um
yeah
um and you have been saying that like
it has been really cool to witness
outside of him because
you've never one had a really deep
conversation with him yeah so having
these deep conversations i think it's
more eye opening for him
because for me like i've been
thinking in retrospect a lot right i've
always been thinking like what what was
it that didn't make my parents work out
i want to make sure none of that comes
to our relationship what are some of the
failures that my parents have because
that is the responsibility of the
generation behind where they are the
living example of what to do and not
what not to do right so as many bad
things i take away the good things too
but um
i think for my dad he's never seen
like all the growth that i've had
through building all these businesses
and living through life so me being able
to explain things to him like he was he
was like
oh [ __ ] this guy's
[ __ ] knows a lot more than i thought
you know like even when my dad was
trying to pitch the idea
of like um
i'mma live with your mom and all that
and i'm like
you know when you speak to someone dad
you gotta speak to them in their
language
and he's like what do you mean he goes
why wouldn't your mom want that i'm like
because my mom is mom and you is you and
i and i brought the example i'm like he
said that why why wouldn't your mom want
that yeah because i think in his mind he
goes everyone wants a family you know
that's how he thinks everyone is
he thinks like everyone and everyone
thinks i can yeah that everyone wants
family and i'm like hey dad i'm like
let's say that a stray dog came into
town you're trying to be friends with
the stray dog
i was like you love [ __ ] mercedes
right it's a nice car and i was like
yeah i was like let's say you wave the
keys at the dog you know the dog will be
your best friend he goes no he starts
laughing i'm like
if you want i'm like what if i gave a
steak to the straight dog your straight
dog and be closer to me and be friends
and he's like yeah i'm like why because
you're speaking the straight dog's
language
this that's you got to speak to people
at what they want not what you want i'm
like you talking to mom and pitching her
this idea is literally waving mercedes
keys at a dock i don't think the dog's
going to bite and i don't think the dog
even cares because you're not even
considering
one single thing that that
dog wants you know yeah
so like that's those are like the type
of conversations that i've been having
with my dad which is pretty crazy
because it almost feels like the turns
table you know
the tables have turned the tides have
shifted yeah
damn do you feel like a man
no i think okay
adult
uh no i think i'm just more sad at the
situation why
i mean i just want my parents to be
happy
but
you know people are really truly the
source of their own misery a hundred
percent right like some people they have
the mercedes and they're like my life
sucks yeah like the [ __ ] i'm blue
dabba dubba dubba about this [ __ ] guy
that has everything but he's still
[ __ ] sad boy yeah and then some
people don't have much and they're the
happiest people in the world so your
reality is literally your own perception
right
so it just makes me sad that uh you
can't help it they don't know that yeah
you can't help them see it yeah my dad
doesn't know it's the story he's telling
himself yeah that makes him unhappy not
that the actual thing is making him
unhappy yeah isn't that gnarly yeah
it's like how do you help
that's
that's the tough part i don't even know
i'm trying to but i don't even know how
to help and i can see why like that
whole obligation method works
because you just do what you're supposed
to do but then at the end of the day um
i don't know if anyone's heart's getting
fulfilled does that matter
um
i think it depends
it depends on who's seeing the light and
who has it
so if you're working with a group of
people and no one has seen the light i
don't think it probably doesn't matter
everyone just do what they're supposed
to do yeah right but the minute you have
someone that goes like me for example
i saw
what life could be
if i controlled it what our relationship
could be if i control that what our
family could be
when i controlled it i'm like that's
what i want now
and so the doing things by obligation
without fine-tuning things
and maximizing the potential of
everything in my life
it's gonna be
sub-maximal so i'm like i don't want
that yeah you know
but if i didn't see that i could easily
be like okay dad wants to like do this
every single time we'll just do well
just but then we're all just kind of
just going through the motions and we
just all keep doing it you know
yeah yeah i mean damn i'm happy that
you're having these conversations you
know and you're getting to see what you
need to take cause i feel like there's
something about
being suppressed that's just never good
never good for the soul never good for
the brain never good for like health
you know so i'm like part of me is
really happy that you're having these
conversations because now it also
um i don't even know if you realize that
you're doing this but it also sets the
tone and lets your parents know that hey
i'm also very much capable this is how
i'm thinking these are the steps that i
do take into account when i am planning
or
living my life and thinking about the
future so when the time comes that you
do need for me to take care of you you
know you're in good hands and i think
you've actually done that with your
parents where they've both you've told
me they both independently told you that
like wow like you have grown so much and
that you're like really smart and like
you make really sound decisions yeah
even a boundary that i started sitting
with my mom is my mom can get into these
texting sprees
and then because she's retired right so
she doesn't have anything to do so
she'll text me something in the morning
and i reply
and then maybe in like two hours later
she texts something and then i'll reply
and then an hour later she takes
something and i'll reply and then 30
minutes and then now she wants to just
have like a full-on text conversation
and it just gets rapid more rapid
like that
so like i'll literally just text like
hey i'm at work i can't talk to you
um because i need to let her know like
um i don't have your time if it's
important i'm always accessible but the
frequency isn't as if i'm retired yeah
so i have to set that down whereas i
think before it would have i would have
dropped everything like early jk if she
called me on set i'd be like oh [ __ ] hey
mom what is it
and oh there's [ __ ] strawberries in
the refrigerator like this it's probably
usually some [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i
remember you guys were talking for hours
every day but now it's like i really i
gotta like i gotta control my life you
know and then what in my life what do i
need to do what are my important things
and i prioritize her unfortunately not
as number one because i might have my
own family that's number one so and if
she has an emergency
i have direct access to her she's like
she can hit me up and if she goes it's
emergency i'll drop everything obviously
but i'm not gonna drop everything for
like hey i made this cappuccino you
gotta try this you know yeah yeah yeah
balance
well damn you're growing up that's
[ __ ] awesome
good for you and i like that you do it
in a way that's still very respectful
like i never see you get riled up while
you're talking to your dad at least um i
never see you like really being a
complete [ __ ] [ __ ] you know where
it's coming from a place of like
resentment rather than like a place of
growth and like setting like you said
those healthy boundaries so it's really
rad to witness
um and i feel like it's for the long run
it's gonna be really healthy for the
whole family
yeah i hope he takes in what i'm saying
it seems like it right yeah it seems
like it he's told me that he says that
he's going to listen to what you're
saying and that you're making really
sound decisions
and like i i mean unless you're making
that up
no that's what he said you know but i
also know i just know a lot of
older people are stuck in their habits
of course so i might give him something
and he's like oh cool i'm shifting my
thinking but if i leave him up to his
own devices he could easily go back to
100 and that's going to happen over and
over and over again but i think you just
have to keep
doing you and remembering your whatever
boundaries you set and and making sure
that you stick to
what you set
forth you know like you can't back down
either you can't be like hey mom i'm
working but then tomorrow i'll be like
yes so what did you need okay yeah let
me jump yeah i mean like you have to
uphold it as well and of course
yeah and it's expected that they're
going to go back on it because that's
all they know yeah both everyone
everyone but yeah both of my parents
have been trying to like suck me hey you
know your dad said this i'm like
um i'm sorry but you need to tell him
you guys are two adults and i told you
from the beginning this is a
this is a b conversation i'm gonna see
my way out of it yeah this is [ __ ]
hated that this is an important thing uh
this is an issue between two people so
you guys
handle it you know you guys are both
adults here yeah that's really good yeah
dang
no but i think that's the way to do it
or else you're gonna keep getting sucked
in so yeah my mom was like she texted me
that she's like you know what i actually
changed my terms can you let your dad
know
like you know her little rules
and then i was like um i'm like no you
let you need to let dad know that you
changed the terms
and then uh cause she was like i guess
she started to feel sorry for him he's
like he can't really hear so i guess
someone does need to help him so can you
tell your dad that i'm like
no you can tell if you want to help dad
you can tell them that uh you can help
him
and then she was like what you don't
care about your dad i know i love my dad
and i care about him clearly he's living
with us now exactly that's exactly what
i wrote i was like yeah my dad's living
with me for for a few months now i have
been taking care of him but um
any type of relationship or
communication from you needs to go to
him yeah yeah because it's not um it's
not cool to get dragged into the middle
of things like that yeah because now
like
so you will hear
that but there's so much baggage behind
it that they need to resolve if they
even
i mean they don't need to resolve it was
already resolved when they got divorced
that was the resolve because they
couldn't resolve it yeah
so like to put you back into that
position is not
not cool yeah recently i visited my mom
in l.a yeah and just talking to her just
to check up on her as a person yeah so
obviously this side thing is going to
pop up of course um and same thing with
my dad
he
he was just venting to me and then the
side thing will pop up both of them
dealing with each other and they're both
trying to like um justify
why the divorce happened and who was in
the right and who was in there
on both of them i think i could pretty
much repeat the exact same speech
i just stopped i stopped both of them no
my speech oh i stopped both of them and
i was like i don't mean any disrespect
but i'm gonna stop you right there
and then to both of them and i was like
um
i will never ever
know the truth
and honestly that doesn't even matter i
was like because
when something like as big as this
happens
i've seen this happen so much in my own
conflict resolution with people it's
always going to be
well i only did this because that
and the other person said well i only
did that because of this right there's
no resolution there's zero resolution
unless both parties are down to look at
themselves and be like i [ __ ] up yeah
no no i really [ __ ] up yeah and
now it's gonna require those two and me
and we have to have a dependable memory
which this is 30 years in the past so
who knows what kind of story because you
know like
once you tell your stories like yours
you start telling the same story to
yourself and it starts warping like you
play telephone with yourself right
so i'm like and who knows
who remembers what
and if you're if both of your memories
as 70 year old people are even
dependable i'm like that doesn't even
matter because if i know who is right or
wrong it's not even going to change the
amount of love that i have for you guys
anyways right what is it i just want to
be a good son to you guys individually
if you guys are able to squash that
that's freaking awesome you guys repair
yourselves i will love you guys as a
couple now but it has nothing to do with
me and so i don't even want to hear it
and then i think both of them were like
oh [ __ ] that's crazy
yeah
because i don't even want to hear the
venting of it you know because it's
unproductive it is it's completely
unproductive
so i was like i came here
to check up on you i didn't come here
to hear about to like
to to see who was right or wrong on the
divorce i just want to know how you're
doing
yeah and then how can i be a better son
to you yeah
um
in a healthy way not in a let's [ __ ]
gossip together oh yeah dad's a scumbag
oh yeah mom's just come back you know
what's your bikini which is crazy that
like
when you're a kid you view your parents
as superheroes you know all-knowing and
annoying and then as you get older
you're like damn they're human they're
just human beings that also like to
gossip are also petty are also this you
know yeah
yeah yeah well damn we got a lot to
learn i'm really happy that you're
having this growth and i'm happy that
this is happening and i'm also happy
that your papa's also having growth and
your mom's having growth even though
they don't like it or they might not
like it or they might like it i think
growth is always necessary to like
elevate yourself to the next level
whatever that level may be
um so damn i can't wait to see what
happens in the next few months we'll do
another recap
well until then y'all thank you so much
for tuning in and we will catch you next
week bye